the
two steps that we're not going to look at today are
saving the weights of the model. So there are a few
file formats in which you could save the parameters of the model like
CSV. There's one called H5.
And another thing we won't be looking at in this course is deploying the
machine learning model. So go to something like AWS or Google
cloud and deploying this.
Depending on the model you or Library. I should say you may have
to
going to something like compute engine
or
An ec2 instance on AWS and then
you would need to use Docker to download the
image and create a container. So
it will go into more of envelopes.
That's what it takes to deploy machine learning model. In other
cases if using Library like tensorflow on Google Cloud specifically
you can just upload the script and go Cloud
will take care of
You know preparing the environment and by environment, I mean installing operating
system on the the hardware.
Installing the right version of python installing the library dependencies.
Let's switch then now until this,
you know is cooking at the background.
and talk about
activation functions first let's talk about
Revenue, and then let's talk about softmax. So this is
a very simple.
neural network
so this
Is this line of code here?
now, of course for the input, we don't have a tensor
the input for
this network is only two features.
And the dense is three so we have three outputs.
Okay, let's see. Now. We said that neural network
are neural networks.
Our matrices but this is a graphic.
representation
I also have a matrix representation up
here.
Let me see if this one has the activation. This
one does have the activation. Yes.
This is actually what a neural network is doing.
So let me show you the graph representation, then we'll look at the Matrix since
we've already covered, you know.
matrix multiplication we can
we can talk about this. Let me come up here. So let's say we
have I will use again the
the real estate example
And let's say this is a very simple.
classification model
so
we want to classify a property.
By its category. So for example, is it a warehouse?
or is it a
is an apartment a residential apartment?
Or let's say commercial property like an
office space in a building or apartment residential apartment.
So how are they different you can have two properties that are similar in
size?
but
with offices you have less.
partitioning
You have fewer doors because you don't have any rooms.
No kitchen. Maybe you have a kitchen you don't
have.
a balcony
and maybe it's just
What's the word I'm looking for more open?
Like there are no enclosing there are no partitioning essentially.
So let's say I want is the number of
rooms in the property and number two is the
size of the property exactly wrong open
floor plan.
Open floor plan.
So obviously there's more to
There's more things that we could
describe to distinguish these two. But again, the point
here is to understand what an activation is.
And this is the context of really.
I want is the
number of rooms I too is the size of the property.
And we have three.
Perceptrons in our one hidden layer.
So this is one hidden layer.
one input one hidden one output
What comes out of this output layer?
is
is the is the classification is a type 1
a property or the type 2 property? Okay. Let's
see how this is done.
So what we do is if you look at these arrows that
stem from for example
I2.
I too will send to every perceptron.
its value
however
It is not just setting the feature. It is also sending a random
weight and a different way to each perceptron.
So for example, they first perceptron might
get a weight of 5.
The second perception may get a weight of one.
And the third perception might get a weight of 10.
So one perceptron will consider the feature to be someone important
on another one not so important
another one very important.
And then we do the same thing with the first feature.
We send the value
to all three perceptrons, but we associate it
with the with different weights.
That's what the slide is about.
So this is nothing more than
some arithmetic
So here we can see we have the feature multiplied by its random
weight.
We have the second feature.
and of course all of this
everything is happening inside the crystal chapter. That's what
you that's why you have this summation.
or this Sigma Sigma represents summation
anyway
We multiply each feature by its rather wait.
So you only have two features here. So.
And since this is for the first picture perceptron, we'll multiply
it by this way. And then we have the the sum of the products.
So let's say
that
this sum is 32.
We will then take this number 32 and pass it to the
activation function this Greek letter of Phi.
represent the activation function
which what does this activation function? Well, it depends.
It depends on what you use for your layer.
These are the
activation functions you can choose
So this is the rectified linear unit.
For the others, I'll show you. I'll take you to the playground to talk
about this.
now for the
for any layer, except the output layer you never
want to use
A linear activation function or here as it's
known as the identity function.
because
well, let me tell you about let me tell you how really works
and then you'll see why you don't want to use the leader function.